[Music]
black mirror time once again and I'm
kicking off the second season with be
right back now in case you haven't been
watching my reviews of these things
there will be spoilers that's why I put
it in the title so this one was it was
not as gut-punching to me as I'm sure it
probably would have been for some people
I mean I've I've lost people in my life
but not people that I've had the kind of
relationship that these two characters
had that said I mean I did I did choke
up but a few points it what this one is
is sad this one is sad as opposed to you
know traumatizing or disturbing or under
it's just sad and and it does that
effectively so when I say doesn't have a
gut punch what I mean by that is it
doesn't have a single moment that's like
the oh you know twist the night kind of
thing that's not really here it's more
just spread out across and sort of there
are certain moments where it sinks in a
bit more just how sad this situation is
but there it doesn't get you know just
sort of encapsulated in a single moment
the way that it that it often does in
other episodes so the whole thing is
it's a really interesting examination of
grief and of trying to process grief and
how do you move forward how much do you
hold on to is it healthy to hold on
is it healthy to move forward which way
does human nature go and is that good
for us you know all these things are in
there and I feel like the level of
escalation as it built up was done
really well I initially when we got the
actual artificial body
I got sceptical because honestly I had I
was kind of getting really interested in
her sort of connecting so firmly with
this AI you know through the voice
through the
next and there was something about that
that like I was getting this vibe of she
was gonna be in this kind of a weird
permanent long distant relationship with
with somebody who was dead
and I kind of found that really
intriguing and then there was part of me
that was going did they overstep
actually giving him a body but then they
took it in directions that it actually
does work cuz there's a couple things
that happened and the first is is that
he actually oddly becomes less
convincing as ash once he's there and
you're seeing him as opposed to just the
tacit certainly the tacks are or even
just the voice there's something about
seeing him sort of have his moments of
did I do that right where when you're
just healing hearing it yeah oh okay but
when you when he kind of just goes blank
faces and is seeking guidance for what
he's supposed to be doing that that
really does make it seem far less real
and then initially when she's when she's
with him for the first time I mean she's
begins connecting with him so hard that
becomes just again very sad because
you're like the it's so blindingly
obvious that that he's not the real
thing and then the little things start
to crack through it's it's a bit it's a
bit of an uncanny valley effect or at
least I feel like that's what they were
revoking he's so close to being a she is
so so close but it's all the little
things it's the fact that he has to stop
and check about how he should be
responding whenever there's something
going on that he doesn't have a frame of
reference for based off the guy social
media footprint and it's all these
little things these little nuances he's
he's got all this but then he's missing
that and you know the whole uncanny
valley thing of the closer it is to
being precise the more every single miss
just stands out all the more and it's
off-putting and it becomes off-putting
for her and as that moved along and this
like so many black merab so the ending
really does solidify everything
beautifully
the the whole thing with you know this
daughter who has in a way gotten to know
her father which is oddly sweet and her
daughter seems to be way more at peace
with what the reality of the situation
is then than Martha is but at the same
time it is kind of you know are not
pudding but just the fact that he's up
in the attic and and especially coming
off the what happened before getting cuz
when when they were at that cliff edge
and she was telling him to jump and he
said he would and then she said no you
should be scared and then he was very
convincingly like that was a that was a
point where like he started being said
I'm like that's really artificial but
then he really started to get a grip on
it as he saw its impact on her and I was
like oh god it went to black and I
thought that was it I thought it was
gonna end like not being clear if she
let him jump if he jumped if she jumped
with him I thought it was just done
there so coming off of that moment to
then the revelation that he didn't jump
but he's just he's in the Attic the same
as the pictures that this guy's mother
had put up there of her other son of her
husband when they passed away because
you loved them too much to get rid of
the memory but you also can't look at it
anymore and that it's just that push and
pull of not wanting to let go but not
being able to deal with the pain of
trying to hold on and that that very
human nature push-pull conflict of what
you want and what does and doesn't work
and now solidified in a walking talking
entity that's in her attic it's it's
just so melancholy just so sad like I
said this one you know doesn't go for
the I mean there are moments that are
a little unnerving but it doesn't go for
the disturbing it doesn't go for the
unsettling it doesn't go for that
sinking sense of dread that I sometimes
get from black mare it just goes for sad
and it it uses this imaginary technology
to really explore how hard it is to let
go how hard it is to move on it's an
exploration of a human response to
something horrible that sometimes
happens to people and it's done really
well it could have been really gimmicky
it could have been really you know
cheesy and really overly blunt or overly
pointed because like I said it's it's an
exploration of grief it doesn't seem to
have a definitive statement on it but it
is a wonderful capsulation and an
exploration of a slightly exaggerated
but at the same time very realistic
reality of what grief feels like and you
know someone's gone and you want them to
still be there but they're not and you
hold on to whatever it is that you've
got around you that reminds you of them
but then it's not actually them and you
you can't bring yourself to get rid of
it but you can't look at it anymore that
it's just it's it's a wonderful
exploration and analogy and embodiment
and literalization of what so many
people have to go through it's really
well done and it feels kind of low-key
compared to some other black mirror
episodes but this is good stuff as this
show has always been for everything that
I've seen up to this point which again
all of season four of season one now
starting season two so I've got this one
to go through then I've got season three
and then I'm done and that'll be it'll
be a little sad but for right now be
right back did you see it what were your
thoughts on it
whatever they were drop something down
the comments let's talk about it there's
all those things you can do things like
support me on patreon or follow me on
Twitter or listen to my podcast
links for all that stuff is down in the
description so until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]